we're going to move on to a whole nother
story someone else has talked at the
table time uh this is a topic that is
topic a and a lot of households right
now the soaring price of groceries last
month we learned that food prices even
as other things fell they actually Rose
13 and a half percent they're up that
much since August of 2021 that is the
largest yearly increase since 1979. so
here's what we did we sent Meg Oliver to
the store with Consumer Reports expert
Brian Vines to show us some small ways
that you right now can still save big
if driving to the grocery store was
already a chore you dread it these days
it may feel extra daunting the price of
groceries seems to keep on soaring
according to Consumer Price Index the
price of food has risen more than 10
percent year over year so today Brian
Vines from Consumer Reports is meeting
us to explore why prices are so high and
to give us some helpful tips on how to
save big even in small ways are you
ready we stay ready all right let's do
it let's go so what can we do to save
money Wednesdays are the universal best
time for grocery shopping between 8 and
10 a.m stores are stocked for that
Thursday to Sunday Rush where
supermarkets do 80 of their business so
you need to plan a schedule absolutely
and the last four days of the month
where you get the deepest discounts
because stores are ready to turn over
for the next month fruits and vegetables
are essential how can we shop smarter
for them fruits and Vegs are at the peak
of perfection right now but Frozen is
always ready and they're just as
nutritious and you can stock up and save
them it beats the season and uh gives
you savings all year long does it help
to buy fresh produce and then freeze it
you can absolutely do that if there's a
deal on Fresh Produce buy it cut it
freeze it it's ready for smoothies
anytime you want unit pricing can be
your friend especially for
non-perishables like this water that you
could buy a bottle for about a dollar
thirty three a quart but these in bulk
33 cents a quart and how do you cash in
on special member deals oh this is where
you're going to need your phone there's
so many stores that offer special member
pricing if you join their savings club
and it translates into real value in the
store and sometimes times even at the
pump and how about when it comes to
protein protein prices are skyrocketing
so fight the urge to run right to the
meat aisle beans are a terrific high
protein option Taco Tuesday doesn't
always have to be ground beef get some
quinoa some beans corn mix it up mix it
up and I'm assuming eggs would be a
really good option eggs are a perennial
favorite they're high in protein it's
clean and you can mix it in and use them
so many ways eggs are a key winner all
right let's not forget dessert come on
Brian here it is we have found my happy
place mine too listen reduce for quick
sale if your grocery store does not have
one of these find a different store how
much can you save fifty percent off
everything here is half off so you can
feel guilty for stocking up on it okay I
won't I won't go the neighbors will eat
something
I have a family of five how much could I
save with these tips my family of two
has saved three hundred and forty
dollars so far this year just using the
in-store savings app wow
just from the tips today we saved more
than 20 bucks all right not bad
for CBS mornings I'm Meg Oliver with
Brian vines in the Bronx New York
[Applause]
a lot a lot of good tips there I know
some people be groaning when he said
beans instead of meat you know chicken
and beef but I tell you what if you take
a pot of beans and you put the Rind of a
Parmesan like parmesan cheese right in
there and a little olive oil it will
come out as rich as anything you're
going to get in section that is my tip
of the day are you doing this alone
because beans always give you lots of
gas you know it's a family sitting there
alone with his beans but when he said
Taco Tuesday without ground beef how can
we do that with the parmesan rinds
you know like yes yes but Brian Bynes
always bringing it we love that and love
his hair thank you Brian thank you very
much Meg